So, we've determined that we want to figure out which set of parameters provide
the best predictions for our output variable, but how can we do that?
We'll use an algorithm called gradient descent.
First, we need to define some cost function, which we'll call J of big theta.
I'm going to use big theta here, to represent our entire set of thetas, and
I'll use this notation throughout the rest of this lesson.
The cost function is meant to provide a measure of how well our
current set of thetas does, at modeling the observed data.
So, we want to minimize the cost function's value.
As we discussed just a moment ago, when we're doing linear regression,
our cost function J of theta, can simply measure the sum of the squares of
the differences between our predicted and observed values.
I am going to formalize this a little bit, and say this, J of big theta, is
equal to one half, times the sum from i equals one to m, of y predicted of x i.
Minus Y observed i squared.
Where Y predicted x i, equals the sum of n from zero to big N, of theta n x n i.
So, there's a lot going on here, and I have color coded this.
So, why don't we walk through it.
First, we're just saying that J of big theta is equal to one half,
times the sum over all of our data points, of the predicted Y,
given our Xs, our input variables, minus the observed Y squared.
So, this is just our error squared term.
Summed over all the data points.
No different than the equation that we have up here.
Down here, we're just defining the way that we calculate the predicted
value of Y.
Given our input variables.
And the way that we do that, is that we say we sum from N equals zero,
to big N, of theta N times X N.
So, we're just saying that we sum up the X N each input variable,
times its weight, theta.
This is no different that the sum that we had, on the last slide.
Note that we include an N equals zero term here, which corresponds to a constant
term in our model, which doesn't correspond to any of the input variables.
For those of you familiar with linear algebra, if we wanted to,
we could also express this as theta transposed times x.
If you don't know linear algebra, don't worry about this,
this is just another way of expressing the same thing here,
that might be easier for some students to comprehend.